[Music]
[Music]
welcome to this show this is a real
chart show as you will see new leaked
women butt-nik Italy as you know some of
them from you are from Italy and some
are not but Italy is a truly fascinating
countries in terms of what's happened to
it in the last let's say since the 20s
okay because you have to really go back
to the fascist period to understand
what's happened more recently and as you
perhaps know the fastest took Italy over
in 1922 and the regime lasted roughly
until 1944 when the in parts of Italy
continued with the so-called Republic II
no government in other parts it ended
earlier and the during this period Italy
was ruined first slowly and then quickly
between 22 in 1938 in the period in
which the world developed Italy was
essentially static nothing happened
where short periods of my growth
followed by periods of stasis for the
period of contraction why well
essentially because the economic policy
was mistaken from the very beginning
Mussolini made a decision in the early
20s to maintain a high parody that is he
fixed exchange rate at a level so called
Cortana vanta 19 level 90 it was 90
leaders to the British Pound which was
totally inconsistent with the price
level that Italy had at that time as a
result of the war now I didn't mention
that because you know who Italy was in
the war on the side of their lives they
easily won the war with their lives it
was very very hard
it was a great sacrifices out of which
they got very little except essentially
the freeing couple of provinces in the
north which were under Austria so it was
it was a leading a weak state and this
decision was disastrous it cost it'll
even more than it cost Britain to stay
on the gold standard until the 1932
essentially a mistake that has been done
by others but when you try to maintain a
currency overvalued what happens is that
you lose in terms of foreign trade and
the only way you could try to keep it is
by depletion that is by actually gaining
prices down in other words your fixed
exchange rate instead of letting the
exchange rate at the level which is
consistent with your price level and the
other people's price level your first
fixture changing it and then you go to
fix the force the price level to be
consistent with it so there was an
extended period of deflation and
unemployment and the and I think it was
all summed up very well in a famous song
radical revolutionary song or certainly
prohibited song that used to be sung by
many people who were against the regime
which essentially went like this cuando
Bandera Rosa ii tava army
que cosa say manana when we used to sing
the red/black bandiera Rosa you know
bandiera Rosa was the plagues of the
Socialists when we used to have the
social slag at least we would eat
something
Miles's okay second rejuvenates say more
e2 T Dallas it again sir and now that we
have to sing Jo Vinnitsa which is the
song of the regime we die old of
constipation essentially we'll have
nothing to eat so then came the European
war see this was in 28 and lasted
through the worst of the depression in
the other countries then came the
tubular war which was again costly very
costly for the for the Italian people
both in terms of actual use of resources
and because of the fact that the other
countries had a boycott because of
Italy's imitation of the tibia this
so-called Santoni which were not very
serious but enough to produce some
problem and then led to the a
strengthening of a policy which had
already began earlier which was the
policy of self-sufficiency since we
could not import they would produce
themselves and so they started to do
crazy things which the most famous was
the production of bull out of milk
was fantastic bull it costed three times
as much as the rule made by the Sheep
and it's probably not as good I don't
think that I've ever used it but that's
a typical of the errors and the
essentially was highly protected right
and they were almost closed
international trade now then finally
they joined the the war with a with the
Nazis and after the very brief very
token victory against France whether he
occupied a certain portion of the
Riviera which has always been in dispute
but not seriously
for a long time but the talents claimed
had some claim to it then of course they
were impeded by their allies and by the
Germans and the country was essentially
destroyed so they came out in nineteen
at the end of the war in 1942-43 with
the country which was totally down and
there was a period of very wild
inflation which was quickly straightened
out by one of the Italy's notable
economies who was then mr. a now D who
was then governor of the Bank of Italy
and he was able to bring the inflation
at the end with a combination of the
proper policy and the beginning of the
Marshall Plan the Marshall Plan brought
the in goods and that helped to deflate
the speculation people who were sort of
speculating and withholding Goods
hoarding goods in the expectation of
higher prices that was truncated by the
Marshall Plan and so they were able to
end the inflation and there began data
as a miracle rough around nineteen fifty
fifty two there was a very rapid
reconstruction and in the relatively
short period of time they went above
previous peaks and began to grow at a
level which had no comparison in the
world except in Japan and here I'll give
you just one chart now let's see I can
get this right
it's not right oh I see I hadn't right
before no I like this remember how to do
it anyway this is the read of growth the
read of growth you can see that in the
beginning only in 1960 essentially I
don't have the period before that by
1960 was the beginning of the real
development and you can see that they
were exceedingly high rates of growth
reaching six and eight and six percent
in the early 60s and then down
essentially 63 and then by 64 you had
the first episode of inflation and
contraction produced by monetary policy
essentially in 64 the rich full
employment and there was an amorphous
explosion of wages wages went up because
they really had reached the bottom of
the barrel of manpower that reached full
employment and gone beyond and there was
a burst of inflation and the Bank of
Italy had a very tight policy which
produced a contraction which you see
there in 1964-65 and then they picked up
again and then you have another sharp
oscillations as you can see and you will
see them in other forms which
essentially correspond to the valuations
so one of the characteristic think for
instances of the period is that you see
that there is a spike in after 72 and 73
74 is a spike very high level which was
of course a typical error of policy
because this was the time of the first
oil crisis when there was wild inflation
all over the place and
proper policy was to try to keep things
cool and that the Germans were very
successful the Japanese extremely
successful they were able to avoid
inflation almost completely but the
Italians we're already involved in this
period in which the union's were pushing
very hard to expand and the central bank
actually accommodated that and produced
this very high peak two years later
there was a devaluation because the
price level was had become totally
uncompetitive they are losing reserves
and they had no choice but to float the
leader there was a sharp devaluation and
contraction now the important thing of
course you can see here that the growth
was positive with very few exceptions in
fact the only real exception is 1993
which is the year after the sharp
devaluation of 1992 which I will speak
separately so essentially I'm
concentrating now on the period till
1992 which is the period of the miracle
in the following sense that if you look
at the whole on the whole the growth
rate was on the order of four percent or
higher during the period from 92 from
1960 to 1992 which is the crucial year
where things happened as you will hear
in the moment which is second the second
miracle occurred in the year but up to
that point
GNP rose three and a half times ok and
at the same time population was fairly
stationary Italy has ever since in
Mussolini's time the population growth
was slowing down and Mussolini made a
great effort to push for a larger
population and the way Premier paid for
people who had many children and they
were regularly shown in the press the
the great Italian families the the large
a Familia Tatiana
and or receive by Mussolini asan had
seven children or more they were elected
to be to meet with Mussolini and be
congratulated it didn't get any far as
far as when those didn't produce any
effect or perhaps it did because after
the war the slowdown has been more and
more conspicuous so that in a Catholic
country which is supposed to be very
attend ready
paying a lot of attention to what the
Vatican said essentially population has
become stationary and now is declining
it's actually one of the very few
countries in the world where population
is actually declining and you can see
houses that are empty because there
aren't enough people to inhabit them
essentially including the centres of
towns so the population grew only by 25%
during these 14 years so that if you go
and examine what it means on the per
capita output three and a half times
growth of output 1.1 and the quarter
growth of population you find that the
per capita growth of income was 2.8 in
other words the income increased by
almost almost treble per capita income
almost trebled in this period and the
country grew from a really poor country
by the time Mussolini had finished
people really had little to eat and
little to where you literally people
would be have no shoes if he went into
the south into the little villages
people literally had no shoes were very
poorly fed and so on gradually into a
country which was almost normal into a
prosperous country by 1992 or even now
you cannot fail to be impressed when you
visit Italy by the fact that people
our well-dressed in fact better dressed
and I cannot thought their shoes cost
hundreds of dollars they are well fed
they eat well in expensive restaurants
they spend in all directions and on top
of that they save a very large amount
now in the initial period when they were
growing so fast what would you expect
what people would take in this course
know that when when the economy when the
income grows fast that's when people
save the debt ceiling depends on growth
in those early years where Italy look
very much like Japan and that
essentially is through the 60s until
1969 a crucial year through that period
Italy grew about as much as Japan not
quite but nearly and saving was as high
or even higher than in Japan the saving
rate reached 24% okay which was higher
than just about the same as the high
point in Japanese history then of course
left everybody amazed because they the
the indications were that there was no
reason to expect them to save a lot
after all who saves well people that
come from the anglo-saxon recall the day
the religious Calvin called Calvin
Calvinistic ethics that's where people
say right like in this country 3% but in
every if it's a Catholic country why
should they ever seen well the fact is
that when you grow you say we grew very
quickly and they saved a lot and that is
of course even more than that even for
given growth they save somewhat more
than other countries for given growth
however the situation has changed
enormously with time as you can see
growth has declined and essentially
the saving rate well why it has a
decline all right perhaps I'll go to
that welcome back to the ceiling late
well essentially in the midst of this
miracle in terms of productivity okay
there was with the life of the italians
was made miserable by the six plagues
okay what are the six plagues inflation
and i'll show you in a moment during
this forty years prices went up twenty
times
wages went up 50 times price went up
twenty times the rest is productivity
the per capita growth and unemployment
grew from about three and a half percent
in nineteen before the at the time
before the first tighten of the central
bank which occurred in sixty four in
that period unemployment was down to
about three and a half percent the
lowest ever seen from that point on
unemployment has kept rising let me show
you that
like me you may not have done employment
do you unemployment this in she has
grown from three and a half to about
twelve percent they soar higher and
there is the figures keep changing
because of the visions and because of
the fact that they now have adopted as
the standard European concept which is
different they mean the crucial question
is how do you define unemployment and
Italians defined unemployment as anybody
who would have accepted a job okay so
they would ask a person if you were
offered a job would you take it and many
people said yes because they didn't ask
that what conditions you know at some
which anybody would accept a job I
suppose
so people said yes and then they would
treat this unemployment later on they
cut the the method of measurement has
become standard for the world including
this country and it consists in asking
whether you have actively looked forward
in the last two weeks okay if you have
actively look for work then you're
treated as unemployed if you are not you
treated as not it's not in the labor
force and that has made the fair amount
of change I mean at some point the
statistics attendances xscape about 13
percent unemployment in their definition
which came down to a little over 12 in
the new definition now so you have had
gigantic inflation and gigantic rise in
unemployment and the
this by the way is they rise in real
wages of which we spoke before you can
see it how is it like Oh God so I
convinced myself that that is the right
way this is you can see that real wages
have risen consistently and continuously
that's how they managed to rise about
three times in this video okay per
capita income little lesson three real
wages are lowered
just about three consistently of course
mostly between 70 and 80 but they are
rising that's a logarithmic scale so but
mostly I'm sorry
this is yes I think this is look at it
yeah it is look at it exhale yeah yes
it's not easy good
just the causes for increased
productivity the causes for the
Christmas DD well good question
very good question first of all in
general there is a very hard question to
answer however we do know this that the
miracles which you now have seen of
country growing first miracles were
Italy in Japan growing for a while above
6% 678 but as the United States never
grew more than three and a half or four
at the very highest point now it's below
two it's always been known that this
phenomenon is the result of two
fundamental features the existence of an
intelligent well-trained labor force if
you have a century people that could do
fairly complex tasks okay with
technology which has been developed
elsewhere okay in the beginning
discussed is to not develop a new
technology they just imitate in the
imported technology and they can then
grow very fast they also need chemical
but occurs in the post-war period
capital is being mobile and then once
you begin the rapid growth you begin
this huge amount of saving which helps
you to bring in the necessary technique
the less of the capital so it's this
combination which you have observed
Japan Italy and then Korea Taiwan Excel
etc all of these countries have a very
similar path where they begin by with
very low wages they begin to essentially
use the low wage which can import the
technology and capital for very fast
growth high saving to enable them to
enhance their capital endowment and then
at some point they begin to be net
exporters of capital so in the case of
Italy even in the case of Italy it
happened but not very much because by
that time the growth had slowed down and
so there wasn't really
as much of an opportunity in Japan is
continued now so essentially those are
the essential ingredients okay and Italy
certainly has this endowment of a
well-trained hard-working population
that certainly on top of which easily
sort of developed another unexpected
teacher a tremendous intrapreneurial
capacity there was completely unknown to
Italy and when the the resurgence began
it was driven by the large firms by the
Fiats manipulating the big firms in
Italy they were and the textile and so
on but gradually it was the small firms
that began to grow and of course by now
all the dynamics comes from small firms
a hundred people or less and this is an
incredible an incredible component of
the economy because you have it is
medium and small firms highly
specialized ok and they produce some
small gadget for the whole world
ok now more or less small gadget yes
like in other words these small firms
have very high profitability ratios but
when you look at the absolute level of
profit they're small and into the
absolute level profit is when you
actually need to finance our new
projects or you know any especially on a
large scale
so do things that relevance the small
size of the Italian average company is a
good thing or a bad thing for you know I
think the economy with the small firms
is in a very good shape
they make plenty of money I don't know
exactly where the profits go how did you
make when you say they are not high I'm
not sure knowledge bases but they're
very small and so when they have to
compete with large I mean look percent
basis is independent of size if every
firm makes twenty percent okay then the
whole country makes twenty percent of
them relative to what they need small I
mean let's put it this way there is no
question that one of the problems of
Italy is the difficulty of financing and
that is because of the fact that these
firms have either to finance themselves
in a self-financed or get credit and
there is really no market except banks
and the banks are inefficient and
monopolistic and very exploiting very
much exploiting so it makes it hard to
obtain the necessary caralyn now they
have been some ingenious attempts at
developing things and improving things
one of the notable Italian inventions
are the credit cooperatives that is what
they do it because essentially the banks
say you are small I don't trust you
you're small I don't trust you and so on
and so forth they band together
and they guarantee each other and they
present themselves to the bank as one
unit which which demands large amounts
okay or can handle large amounts and
then they get a much better treat but
resentment for the rest other
institutional improvements which should
have come have not because one of the
think that he would like to encourage is
the use of equity capital including the
issue of shares
okay now firms are very reluctant to
issue shares because they don't want to
share the profits with anybody else so
they are quite willing to borrow but not
willing to share into the profits so
it's hard to get them but on top of that
there is no market okay because the
Italian market is undeveloped anyway and
these are small firms so you'll have to
really create a market from that and
there are possibilities in particular it
will be very possible to have funds okay
which divided their investment over many
small firms okay and thereby but that
has never developed in part because the
Italians you see it it's incredible how
capable they are when it comes to
production how incapable they are in
terms of government and the financial
system what have they done they said
will create these funds but you know
what and we don't transport beam a
missile located so therefore they must
liquidate every 10 years I can imagine
that it's just ridiculous because you
invest in something because it's a long
outlook and now if usually you have to
send it okay
I mean that just discourages it and
furthermore when you do sell it you
could clear out a real problem if many
of these funds have to unload at the
same time you can create a real
nightmare so there's a most stupid thing
to do I mean why don't they let the fog
decide how long they want to live I mean
this is the way it is
the direction of a fund they found
establishes that they it will live until
the stockholders to sign or the
management asked the Stockholm the
seclusion then it will end but there is
no natural of death okay it's just a
stupid idea
the idea of having a time in which you
are slick we did everything well I don't
know about that because these firms I
have seen quite a number of these firms
I visited quite a few and they are very
much family managed the father and
children and sometimes of the
grandchildren are those that do
everything do all the decisions and they
have a remarkable ability both from a
point of view of commercial from the
point of view of Technology
and from the commercial point of view
and you know what's remarkable is that
for instance I have spent some time on
the lake alta which is in northern Italy
around the lake there is a large number
of small firms which specialize in Ruby
materia which means faucets literally
speaking faucets for both industrial and
per household and they are very
specialized that is they makes faucets
for a very particular kind of thing and
the old very prosperous whole quite
small and they say alone over the world
okay I mean I don't know how the hand of
the correspondents in in all kinds of
languages but they somehow managed to do
that and one thing that I want to
noticed is that the ability to deal with
foreign markets used to be very much
hampered by one of the characteristics
of the Italians I don't have time to
speak about everything but I have been
recently asked to
give a TV interview on the following
subject the interview that those
interviewed were outstanding Italians
living abroad and the question was what
are the defects what are the
shortcomings of the Italian police only
did see a little alley okay one of the
vices of the Italian and mind apply my
first apply was that the main vice of
the Italians is the phobia okay
know the Italians know what that means
it's essentially means cunning okay or
no cunning
actually the worst kind of cunning they
used to take great pleasure in taking
advantage of each other
okay I can't use the proper word
regarded and that means essentially that
they were very anxious to cheat
everybody except the family these the
insiders and outsiders all the outsiders
were candidates for cheating and they
applied that to their export so the
great delight in cheating to stupid
foreigners who bought from them they can
give them cold merchandise or not
deliver at all or not pay or whatever it
is since the war they have learned to be
scruples then I become excellent ethnic
excellent name in terms of prompters of
exactness of totally reliable now when
they are still our food be they still
are coming is with respect to the
government okay they no longer try to
cheat each other all the cheating is now
done with the government which is not
their family it's not the foreigners
okay
and therefore they don't pay taxes okay
and they are deeply into the habit of
corruption that is they try to get all
kinds of tables by bribing officials who
again are very glad to cheat the
government that still is a great problem
Italians face and which I think
gradually will mature but it
take some time why do you think that it
has occurred in Italy in the growth rate
no it is well you have to see the moment
we'll see why what the problem lies what
cause they slow growth it's not day as
you could see the cause is entirely
different and in the world until 1992
okay there were these six plagues and
let me go over them again inflation I
already told you what happened with the
unemployment I told you what happened
their deficit of the balance of payment
deficit of the of the Treasury of the
fiscal deficit okay corruption okay and
think of the last one and bad government
bad government okay
incompetent dishonest government the
citizen were dishonest to the government
and the government was dishonest with
respect to the citizens respect to its
duty now I will cover each of these okay
let me first look at the first four okay
the first four metrics the first three
unemployment inflation and deficits in
the accountants and foreigners are all
due to one single cause that cause is
the unions okay
it only has I've had very powerful
unions they got together for the first
time in 1969 and they made a tremendous
push for wage increases which gave rise
to
period that has been called the hot
autumn the hard autumn began in the fall
late fall 69 and ended in 70 and let me
show you here something about the first
on the positive side let me show you
something else of the positive side
namely that what contributed enormously
to the productivity growth and to the
actual growth of some extent is this
degree of openness okay
that is defined as the sum of export
plus imports divided by GDP okay and you
can see that in the beginning that was
very small
that was the inheritance of the fascist
self-sufficiency okay
I'm not a citizen even lower was down to
50% of it and it grew Italy got
essentially into this into the world
economy and it had tremendous advantages
it was able to export an import okay
getting thing cheaper selling things
that it could produce well and so on so
you have here a fantastic example of the
advantages of international trade and
that's one of the real important motives
for the growth and productivity growth
now
okay here you have the essence of the
problem that the unions were able to
secure this should really be I guess
like this
I think the read of yes it's written
properly yes it's Robin yes that is your
rate of growth of nominal wages okay you
can see that it never goes below 4% now
there is a fundamental principle to
understand that our economies our our
market economies use a fundamental
method of pricing I mean fundamentally
prices are a markup a fairly stable
markup of a union of a unit labor cost
unit labor cost is the cost per hour
divided by the productivity per hour
okay that is what gives you unit labor
cost in other words it's the cost or
labor but adjusted for how much it does
okay so if you do speed twice as much it
produces twice as much then the cost of
labor per union is unchanged now so
whenever the wages rise more than
productivity what happens that unit
labor costs rises and prices tend to
rise to the extent that they can and
that will have to see a moment how that
goes so fundamentally the inflation is
shouldn't affect that the unions kept
pushing you see the first great push is
in 1964 that's when there was the first
running out of of Labor okay there was a
sharp rise in wages because it was
competing for the little labor available
but the next big big sharp peak is 1970
okay
the later Peaks are higher but that's
during the oil crisis because by that
time inflation was very high
and therefore okay so it's 1970 that is
the crucial point where for the first
time you can see that wages rose about
22% in one year
okay that was way above productivity of
course which was then rising maybe 5% or
so and began producing the inflation now
when you have this huge push of wages of
nominal wages and the unions were strong
enough to be able to impose this higher
nominal wages on business on terms then
what happens well the firms try to push
the higher labor cost into higher prices
okay to maintain the same markup to
maintain the same margin spread the
margin of profits now and here there are
two possibilities either the central
bank accommodates or it doesn't if the
central bank accommodates it means what
it means provides enough money to
accommodate the higher prices and it
means having a floating exchange rates
which are just so that when the prices
rise they firms do not lose any business
needed externally because the external
prices have moved without they're
costing any competitive advantage right
because the the devaluation and the
internal prices internal purchasing
power is maintained through the high
abolish supply so this combination means
that in principle they could pass on the
entire wage push okay but what happens
then and after the central bank is
accommodated and the firm's have
responded with some lag prices have
risen as much as wages - productivity
and therefore the workers have not
obtained the 20% that they wanted so
what's the reaction and they go back and
say but then we want higher nominal
okay and if the central banks
accommodates well they'll get the higher
nominal wages if the central bank
accommodates the prices will rise also
and they will not have it and it will
continue and you have essentially a
fundamentally a wage price spiral that
can go on indefinitely or get worst Y
worst because in the beginning there is
lags okay it takes a time between the
time the firms respond to the wages and
every time the wages multiplies then
people learn that it's going to come and
so anticipate the time and so
essentially instead of inflation being
ten percent per year it becomes 15 or 20
percent per year
okay because it's just the period of
time you get the higher rate of
inflation now what happened in Italy
essentially that the central bank kept
wiggling between the two alternatives
I'm sorry what is the alternative the
alternative eastern central bank to say
no I would not accommodate what happens
then there's going to be some rising
prices anyway because the higher cost
will lead to pushing up prices however
now pushing up prices means losing
foreign markets and domestic markets
because remember that the firm in our
urban economy a firm is selling to the
world on which one portion is Italy okay
so you're now losing market to competing
firms that sell more that you sell less
abroad and you say less at home because
they come and sell at home so you lose
competitive toward the whole world and
when you lose competitiveness occurs
output the clients okay essentially you
have to you have a trade-off between the
two some of it goes into higher prices
some of it goes into lower output and
employment okay and some firms are now
pushed out altogether because the profit
shrink because there is a rise in real
wages to some extent the real wages rise
not as much as meant and of course the
workers also get to a point where as
employment grows they tend to be
somewhat cooled off and they demand less
but in this process what do you have you
have inflation and growing unemployment
okay now normally report economists
thought that when you have rising
unemployment then wages will surprising
right it's natural factor but even the
client if there is enough unemployment
why not
why shouldn't wages decline well the
Italian unions didn't see it that way
they didn't give a damn about the
unemployment they just kept pushing and
pushing and pushing okay so real wages
goes up when up pretty fast but
unemployment grew and it is worse than
that because during this period of
restraint what happens is that
nonetheless your prices have risen your
competitive has declined therefore net
exports have declined
okay and if they decline did not you
find that you cannot pay for your
imports you have reserves you start
digging down your deserves you get
credit abroad after a while you can no
more okay so what do you do at that
point you have no reserves you have no
possibility of credit there is only one
thing you can do
let exchange let go okay so essentially
while you were trying to hold it hold
the money supply and hold the exchange
rate at some point you have to let the
change rate go then you have a very
typical period which is ditalion scald
the appraised of Dragana
the drug repressive would be yes the
drug recovery because this is a short
interval during which essentially the
great growth of exports because suddenly
the Italian goods become cheap because
the leader has gone to the dogs with the
value deeply so the selling there is
more employment they are able to treat
etc and the inflation hasn't yet begun
to be serious so there is a phase in
which everybody is happy but then the
unions realized that they are those who
lost because the effect of the inflation
is precisely that of reducing their
wages prices rise and they come back and
start pushing for an increase in nominal
wages so you then get into another
period in which the bank tries to hold
the line but can't after a while so you
have had in Italy several deep
contractions and they are preceded
usually by phases in which the growth of
output is very low okay before they give
up before they let loose and they have
been devaluation repeatedly now of
course on top of that the inflation was
also fed by the oil crisis and by the
fact that they were very poorly handled
in Italy in the sense that I don't go
into light but the only way you can
handle an oil crisis intelligently is by
persuading the workers that they must
not ask for higher nominal wages because
they are poorer its effect okay they
have to pay the Sheik tax nothing they
can do about it but let me as well Pete
and not try to recover because if they
try to recover all they get is a spiral
and they'll never recover okay so any
attempt Italy let the Union and the
unions and the government let the unions
go wild and they had enormous increases
in wages during this period as you can
see here during that period they had
gigantic 25% 26% increases in wages most
of which showed up in inflation okay
now the this situation this essentially
explains this history of growing
inflation and growing unemployment now
of course all this doesn't occur with
perfect continuity but there are ups and
downs around the whole this is what you
see what you observe now essentially the
periods of of which price spiral and
floating a change usually came to an end
because people were tired of inflation
okay and then essentially they put
pressure on the government to establish
a policy of normal combination okay
whatever it might cost they'd forgotten
the previous crisis so let's try it
again
well this was tried a few times and
didn't succeed and then finally Italy
decided that the way to make this policy
stick this policy of holding the line
the best way was to join the the EMS the
European monetary system so that in 1980
79 80 they they said we were now going
to hold the line and to prove you that
we are going to fix our exchange within
the EMS okay and at that time I
occasionally write editorials for the
career della Sera which is the main
interest in people and I wrote one in
which said if you really mean it
that's the best way to do it because
then you have credibility then you know
the workers will understand that you are
committed to defend exchange rate and
they will have to be careful in pushing
for higher wages and they follow the
period in which on the whole the policy
works that is what happened inflation
very promptly the client
I have to cite I'm burning her you can
see the oil Italy entered essentially in
1980 that spike after entering is the
second oil spike the second oil crisis
you remember that there was a second oil
crisis in seventeen idols just the time
they entered and it was as severe as the
first crisis shorter but was very severe
and inflation was all over the world not
just in Italy but then after that the
present him in the EMS produced a very
sharp decline in inflation which by 1985
was down to almost you know almost
acceptable levels certainly much lower
than they ever had since the 60s okay
now however and here is the interesting
story even though inflation came way
down it still was larger than the rest
of the world still was larger than the
Germans and the French in the rest of
the EMS they had pretty much the same
rate so that they are relative prices
kept getting worse okay now that is what
the economies call let me show you this
I have this here yes what economists
call the real exchange rate okay the
nominal exchange rate is dollars per
lira it's the price of the dollar okay
fifteen hundred so fifteen hundred liras
per dollar the real exchange rate is
goods for goods so many title goods per
forum good okay and you get it
if you deflate the exchange rate but the
price index okay
so that what you look at is whether the
lira depreciates faster or slower than
the prices are rising
okay so yes now if you not look at the
real exchange rate you find that during
this period on the whole italian prices
were rising faster than foreign prices
while by construction the nominal
exchange rate for steadily stable
because they were in the MS that they
had a few devaluation of the way
not so much and then by the lates have
better lead it is they had no more now
on top you have the nominal exchange
rate okay and you have to look at the
period 8592
alright now you see that the in that
period the nominal exchange rate was
just about stable okay
very small changes that with the ems
because that that's what the one that
was fixed the last they were the whole
ems was floating with respect to the
rest of the world and below you have the
real exchange rate okay and you can see
that the real exchange rates kept
getting worse and worse and worst now we
are approaching the end of the first
period
which ends with the famous devaluation
of 1992 let me show you that how that
went so here you can see the real
exchange is getting worst and what
happens when the real exchange gets
worse is that the
net for balance gets worst okay here you
have a very nice little picture in which
you have the the dark line is the
current account balance okay and the
white one is the capital account and
essentially the capital account needs to
compensate the current account or else
you have to lose reserves but of course
the capital account can also act on its
own that is people may decide to invest
capital literally and then it will
either go in an appreciation or into
reserves now you can see that that
negative balances were accumulating
already in the late 80s with one
exception up to 1985 the balances were
negative then there is a little positive
one in the next year and from 1987 known
as the real exchange rate got worst the
net for balance grew larger and larger
and larger now if you look at the solid
line that confirms what I said before
that the Italian inflation while coming
down was coming down was still larger
than the foreign one and the heavy line
is the differential is the third a
broken line is the differential
inflation resume Italian inflation -
German inflation and you can see that
that differential keeps became smaller
and smaller but it's always positive and
this long is dispositive you're losing
competitiveness okay so the balance of
payment got worse and worse now up to
1990 that the difficulty was handled by
the Bank of Italy to attract resources
to make up for the negative balance they
kept raising interest rates and
attracting capital and they were very
successful and there was a while that
people somehow had enough confidence so
that they were quite willing to come in
and invest in Italy for the interest
rate differential
okay so there was a foundation of
confidence by the time you get to 1992
the balance is getting worse okay and
what happens here is that at one point
people realized the italian situation
the italian exchange rate was
unrealistic could not be maintained why
first because it was generating deficits
okay
now the government of course kept saying
you know we're going to change that we
are going to get the workers to accept
smaller changes and we're going to
gradually be able to get out of this but
God knows when okay
but the worst part was that by that time
mass which was coming on and the time at
which Italy was to enter was essentially
in the late nineties okay or mid
nineties now Italy could not enter with
that kind of interest rate that kind of
exchange rate because it was overvalued
it would have to do the same thing as
Mussolini essentially go into a period
of deflation in order to stay very
painful then it costly in terms of
unemployment unemployment was already
very high so here is a country with high
unemployment which has a large data set
which in a short time has to physically
change late
it cannot fix it at the current level I
was at that time 700 to the mark okay so
having decided that Italy could not
possibly avoid devaluation some time
people were smart enough to say well if
sometimes why not now that is now it's a
good time to get out before it happens
after it happens is too late
so mass movement and including
speculators decided that this is a good
time that the Bank of Italy could not
hang on to that parity and so there was
a very sudden withdrawal of funds and
the lira bank of it I didn't have enough
reserves they tried to defend that
change rate they had to give up the lira
collapsed and there was at first in
attempt by the Bank of Italy to try to
save to save the lira okay
that is they tried to avoid too high we
first of all they often a devaluation of
15% if they offer to reenter the system
with the 15% duration it was acceptable
to the partners but not to the
speculators who kept at that price
rushed in and we drew foreign exchange
okay so they had to abandon the 15% and
let it go and it essentially lost over
20% or so then they try to get back into
the MS by high interest rate policy try
to attract capital and thereby bid up
the lira okay because when capital comes
in that builds up the lira right and
they tried that for a while and then
what happens is something of which MIT
can be proud namely Rudy dot bush he
wrote a very famous influential article
to what they eat the end of 92 saying
don't be fooled
don't try high interest rates and don't
try to get back into the tank the
devaluation is helping you export for
years you have had an overvalued lira
now enjoy the appropriate or perhaps
even hundred adulation
okay don't try to keep up interest rate
that kills investment keep low and
interest rates let that the value of the
exchange further that's all good and he
said it came out with his famous
statement that the mark which was then
780 could easily go up to 1,000 okay
I was a tremendous shock nobody could
believe
and I however quickly believed it and
what really matters is that Bank of
Italy began to understand and after his
article they led to lira they gave up
the high interest rate they began
cutting interest rates and the latter
lira the value further until it
essentially reached 1000 then came back
a little bit because capital was flowing
back and the central bank wanted to he
thought a thousand might be too much but
it came down to nine seventy or
something like that and then essentially
you head it costs more leaders we are
talking about foreign exchange you have
a problem because you don't have you
don't earn enough for the change to pay
for the goods so when you devalue
foreign goods costs more but that means
that the that means that you buy less of
them you you surprised let me first of
all I left out one very important thing
in 1992 see I've mentioned the six
plagues and now let me start out by
talking about the second Italian miracle
okay
in 1992 there was a series of events
which suddenly treated all the ills
which had created the plagues okay labor
unions the labor unions after having
spent their life pushing for escalator
clauses okay to the absurd level there
was a point where they push this to the
absurdity that the escalator was called
fixed point escalator which meant that
whenever the cost of living went up by
percent everybody got the same increase
in salary regardless of his weight the
same the same as was appropriate for the
essentially the medium the middle the
median wage okay so if the median wage
had to receive a thousand lira everybody
got a thousand whether you your wage was
very low or whether you were the
governor of the Bank of Italy or the I
guess so they probably gets paid more
than the head of the Republic but anyway
all had to have the same now this was
the most destroying and destructive
system that you could imagine and I made
me absolutely made and I wrote some a
couple of hydron heart articles in the
career della Sera explaining that this
was absurd that it was creating equality
by artificial means okay who's using
inflation as the way of creating
similarity wages okay that if the
inflation kept going on in a little
while they would all have the same wage
you know up to a little difference but
about the same wage and in fact one of
my smart colleagues wrote an article
saying that Paladini was nothing law
wrong with this idea because after all
if you use this in a little while
everybody will have the same Liat wage
at which point the same point was right
you know the fixed point was right
everybody has the same in which the
fixed point was right
okay cuz by that time the system is
kaput and of course I explained that in
addition to the damage in trying to
create that kind of situation it
couldn't and I expected as it did happen
that it increased inflation why because
the employers found it necessary to
maintain the differentials so if the the
this gave the same to everybody then
they had to pay extra to the people they
trusted the people who did their
pleasant things and so on and so forth
so essentially you have in effect that
an initial cost of living produced a
higher percentage wage increase which
produce a higher percentage change etc
so it's actually the system
well that system eventually came to an
end and the notion began that even that
skeletal clothes had to be cooled off
and they first talked about
limiting the escalators to people below
a certain income in the regulations are
not the sticks point but to maintain the
regular escalator just let's say for the
lowest 60 percent of the wage and the
variety of things of this kind and then
there was a student of mine who is now a
great man literally Richard Allen telly
who proposed a method which in effect
came to negotiating in nominal terms but
he used a different language he proposed
the system in which what first of all he
showed the Desolator clauses had the
term of effect that you could never
bring an inflation to an end because of
the legs because this quarter's increase
in wages was last quarters increasing
prices which meant that the next report
that this quadrant increasing prices was
like last quarter okay and then if we
gone to the next one so you could never
or with the greatest difficulty you
could bring inflation down and so he
proposed the pre planning or negotiating
of the escalator clauses escalator tix
you see the escalator tix see heaven
every month it takes by the number by
the extent of increase in wages and he
said let's agree from now how much the
tick will be I take decreasing rate over
the next quarter the next quarter next
quarter but that if you think about it
meant that since the current wages were
known that meant fixing the level of
nominal wages at the growing level at
exceed a level of nominal wages ahead
that was part adopted party not but in
1992 our pathway talent Ellie was
murdered in 1973 I think by 1983 by the
Red Brigades essentially because he was
trying to create peace between labor and
employers and that was the worst thing
anybody could do and but his teaching
had an effect and in 1992 the unions
agreed under a new government by the way
in 92 the first thing that happened
perhaps was a new government finally the
terribly bad government of the Christian
Democrats from 19 from the 60s through
the 90s all more or less Crudup are all
incompetent and all sort of bent on the
same policy which was then of giving all
kinds of things to get votes and pain by
deficits that was the fundamentalist is
the very son you didn't raise taxes say
so you again you get large pensions
nobody had to pay taxes for that because
you would just borrow okay of course the
cost of borrowing means that you don't
have investment because you simply
sacrifice the use of resources for that
purpose so essentially this came to an
end and there was for the first time
since the 60s a excellent government by
mr. Amato he has said she was able to
persuade the unions to accept a nominal
contract
okay that is a contract under which
there was a path of nominal wages was
fixed in advance together with the path
of inflation which was fixed in advance
which would give the workers very little
increase in nómine in real wages which
they were willing to accept in order to
realizing their crimes toward the
unemployed they wanted to make up and
began to be willing to sacrifice real
wages to increasing the capacity to
export reducing essentially the cost of
labour and increasing the capacity to
export so the first miracle then was a
competent government the second was that
the union suddenly became wise and ever
since that they have been exceedingly
wise throughout this period and they may
be even now and my whole programme which
I will discuss next video relies on
their being sensible and there are
indications that they want to be
sensible not the question just how much
is to be seen but the principle is
acceptable to them see my my new book
which I will discuss next time is called
the miracle that's achievable and it is
based on the notion of bringing
inflation down to zero with the workers
help at the head of one of the large
unions has already said that he is in
favor of zero inflation so we are on our
way now the next thing was that the
judges began the famous investigation
into corruption and they found this
incredible amount of corruption much
deeper than anybody had believed so that
at least there was a considerable
improvement if not a solution to the
problem of corruption and all levels of
government particularly at the lower
level okay yes let's call Tangentopoli
as you all know
the problem there were some people they
were that were arguing that all these
heads that were flying due to the
manipulative DiPietro company was
actually stopping a lot of sectors from
from growth for example constructions
but all because no one wanted to put a
signature there because was scared and
then the old he came up with the idea of
you know putting a patch and almost
forgetting what is your opinion about
the identity on the it seemed to me that
any reasonable person must think that if
the only way of getting employment is by
corruption then he better had his head
visited because it's just been over
influenced by imbeciles like recognize
the beauty and the like okay this man
tried to fix the whole thing by saying
that a whole class of crimes would not
be treated as as criminal offenses there
would be a civil think they would be
liable to reimburse the government but
they would not go to jail okay these
people corrupt they made fantastic
amounts of money they have to pay the
penalty clearly now it is true that when
this episode occurred and everywhere
they found that the contracts were
loaded with additional things which
would then feed back essentially the
official accepted a ridiculously high
bid and then in exchange for that he got
money from the bidder now that was
large-scale now clearly that had the
effect for a while of stopping of very
much restraining the the ongoing
contracts people would became very
scared both the people who submitted
bills and those that accepted them and
there was a phase of stages now then
unfortunately came to occur at a time
when the economy was halting was
grinding instead but that you know that
happens to be I mean
you could foresee that and the answer of
course is to have good laws and good
systems to be sure that the contracts
are not loaded that's the answer let's
say well a little bigger option because
and then government has tried that okay
still there's been some delaying and
there's no question about it
yeah here is our expert on labor from
Italy and he knows all about the chisel
which is the union with which I work
most closely
[Music]
indicators I don't see I don't see that
those situations
just-just since you've been figures
around the thing is I have which are the
official figures say that in 1992 then
employment rate was eleven point three
and now it is in ninety five eleven
point seven so there has been an
increased it's negligible unemployment
is now going down now mind you called
the synchronous occurred and most of it
occurred under the regime of Mister the
disco knee the magnate who got elected
on the promise that he would create one
menial jobs and he lost as you see he
lost three hundred thousand I mean I
understand all that sure I mean there
are certainly speeches which one
[Music]
1995 don't ecology statistics depending
from when where the average for the year
went down I mean we have to we have to
move on you have you have a you have a
valid or in other words what you're
saying is that there is no evidence I
mean two things one is that the workers
have ended up losing from this fixed
wage from sorry not fixed wage but fixed
program of producing nominal wages okay
which they have more or less followed in
the end they've lost okay and there
hasn't been much improvement in the
permanent I've touched on these and
explain why
working time first of all was like for
posting frames some time ago in a dream
looks to me like creating more room for
some new people but at the same time it
will be necessary to expand the space
enough to equal a room for some people
that are not employ someone else you're
saying that you don't like this
particular way of reducing unemployment
and of course I couldn't agree with you
more
I think it's just stupid plain stupid
but it's also also infeasible let me
have come to that in a moment
now first let's pursue the set of heads
so you've had I mentioned so far new
government a new union the cleaning up
of the corruption okay and with a fixed
range a deep devaluation now the balance
of payment has made me regulars changes
imports have declined enormously exports
have risen enormously
Italy was running a deficit every year
since then his beer and rising surplus
is speed back its debt it's now
accumulating claims on the rest of the
world incredible effect ok beyond what
anybody wouldn't expected with the lira
pretty high okay now so it was very
healthy and of course as you will see in
a moment it went too far because the
devaluation went too far but that is
where we come to build Estonia
okay now however despite this 93 was a
very bad year ok
why well
the devaluation was a tremendous shock
Italians began to doubt about everything
around them
okay on top of that they was essentially
a warm crisis all over the place
93 was a barrier all over the world okay
and in the market so then there was the
clients in output so there was also
declines in Italy and finally by the
middle and finally Amato imposed some
rather rigid new financial laws raise
taxes quite a bit and began to fight
against the evasion by a famous law that
the sense is required it was a minimum
tax essentially that no matter what you
had to pay at least a certain amount
unless you could show that you
absolutely had nothing okay it was up to
you to show okay there was a doubtful
constitutionality but was effective okay
now then in the middle of the year in 93
the amount of government was replaced by
the chunky government champy was the
former governor of the Bank of Italy a
man of the highest ability and of the
highest moral highest moral qualities
one of the few men in Italy that only
exists in the Bank of Italy I think two
or three that pay all the taxes okay and
I know a couple of other things not
thinking
the former governor did Murphy but he
takes very exceptional people and
searching and Lee who was the Bank of
Italy is one of the two people that pay
all taxes but a very scruples man and he
put together a government of very able
very honest people okay absolutely
highest quality and you know some of
that is known even to foreigners and one
of the things that everybody recognizes
worst-affected
he put in charge of the Minister of
Culture mr. Raum Kay a former editor of
the main paper of Italy who was able to
get museums and other things to function
properly
not closing at the I was when the
tourists want to become I remember
reading an article that said shut shut
up quickly the tourists are coming you
did the plaster anyway but everybody
else was at the highest quality and
there was a man who finally resisted
that very powerful how do you call it
the people that try to get tables from
the government the well you call the
Dania I'm trying to think of the
American word very powerful lobby of the
government employees which is a
tremendous number and they kept getting
higher wage increases than anybody else
and mr. Cassidy was able to impose
disability and issue decrees saying to
the employees of the government remember
that you are working for the public and
not vice versa because when you went to
the post office they treated you as
though they were doing you a favor
when they would sell you the stems and
you sort of explain to them you are
supposed to be the servant of the public
well these were tremendous achievements
but he also raised taxes mister Champy
because he wanted to put financial
condition to straighten out the finances
and some of these taxes were bad and
very much resented the worst of them has
absolutely an excuse of a man never
understood how it was trained for it was
a tax on the amount of money in the
deposit in banks on a certain particular
day that was that wasn't a madam I
thought it was the guy what's his name
man
the minister who was the minister well
they may be a mother but anyone will do
I mean no I guess Chanti had the attacks
of the doctor that are sort of medical
anyway which made him another in popular
name then in the midst of all this very
complicated political process that we
should go into we cannot go into it
essentially mistakes that were made
champy resigned and there were elections
and his coalition was incompetent in the
sense they didn't know how run under the
new system which was a system no longer
proportional representation but the way
colleges in each College you would win
the plurality would win okay and those
conditions if you are smart everybody
that has similar ideas has to band
together and agree to put a single
candidate for the group okay because
otherwise you split the vote and you let
the other side and but Mosconi was
superb in doing it he got the fascist
and the so-called League of the North to
be with him by giving them many more
seats than they should have had he gave
them that he seats
given essentially their men were pulling
the college's there him and they got
election and they won by very small
amount actually I think they lost the
popular vote I think it's a very strange
thing that this time the central left
has won the elections but they had a
small small minority in the popular vote
very small anyway then came this
fabulous quarry okay and the good things
began to be undone okay
mr. Berlusconi was concerned primarily
with his personal fortune he had TVs he
was concerned with the monopoly in TVs
he did not like the competition of the
government TVs so essentially the first
thing he did was to replace the
management with his own friends with his
own people and be sure that it wouldn't
compete with him and so on and so forth
cut the subsidies support in various
ways and beyond that generally concerned
with replacing people with his own
people and had no attention to the
government he failed to pass a financial
law in time it was supposed to pass a
preliminary law by July he later did go
buy the market he'll take it well and
the leader began to
by the way well it's too late to go to
details hunter mr. champion there were
two important things the leader began to
devalue someone but not very much
because it was not appropriate anyway
she remained around a thousand or so but
the spread between Italian and foreign
seen German interest rates death spread
is the best measure of how much
foreigners need to be paid to invest in
Italy it's the best measure of
confidence in the country that thing
went down from about 6% displayed being
six percentage points that is German
interest would be five and he tells to
be 11 okay the short leads to two and a
half which was lower than it had been
since the devaluation and even before it
rarely be so low and interest rates came
down very very very very much
about five percentage points okay still
high but they from 13 to 8 or something
like that and and the there was
essentially some beginning of the
company in spring when he left he left
in the spring of 1994 all right now with
Berlusconi the spread between the
interest rates began rising
systematically and by the end of the of
his staying power had gone back almost
as high as it had been when Sharpie took
over that meant high interest rates that
meant very bad effects on employment but
in some sense the worst part came later
because after he left the government he
began insisting that he had been
displaced by a palace revolution like
the coup d'etat so to speak because he
had one of one component of his group
had bolted and moved to the other side
and he said that was the league and he
said that that was illegal and justified
because they hadn't consulted the
electorate
he said that electors who had elected
the league would not have favored this
movie so that in terms of people he
still had a majority even though in
Parliament he didn't and he kept making
noises that he wanted immediate
elections he want an election in spring
okay
he resigned in December he want election
in spring and the president of the
republic said don't come to me I have no
power persuade Parliament not him it
couldn't be persuaded so it didn't get
election in spring then he decided that
he was going to boycott the government
in the country and when the new
government that replaced him mr. Dini
came in with a law a second financial
law to supplement his financial law
which had been much too weak he then he
and his group decided to vote against
the financial oh okay then they got the
extreme left mr. Peattie not the
leftover of the communist to join them
so that the law the financial law which
everybody agreed was necessary passed by
for votes and then they promised that
they would be calling for confidence
boats every week that gave a scare to
the international markets and the lira
which had been it around a thousand or
below when ciampi left arrived reached
as high as 1300 1280 in march okay now
what was the fact of this it then came
down that slowly and remained above 1100
until very recently what was the fact of
death and the main effect of death was
to increase the price prices to create
inflation because imported goods became
more expensive and don't forget there is
a second effect with a devaluation firms
can sell more abroad and higher
all right they can increase prices
without losing markets because of the
devaluation all right
and when they list prices abroad there
is a bit home too because they are also
protected from foreign competition at
home so there was a general increase in
the cost of living coming from direct
imports and from increased marked-up
markup of the domestic firms all created
by the devaluation and that's why I
tried to explain I was only I think I
have to cut up and I was on a TV show
three days ago I forget just one with
this men of the extreme left that voted
with them against the financial law and
he wanted to reinstate the escalator
clause and cited as a motivation for
that that in the last few months the
workers have lost